こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
けんすけさん今年結構忙しかったので最後
ぐらい盛大に
遊んじゃいましょうよ
[音楽]
なんか今回2億円の船を貸し切りましたー
すごくないですかね
ちょっと見てください今日最高の
クルージングパーティーにしような
ちょっと早速出向前なんですけども1回目
が確認しましょうか船のここから乗るん
だろうな
行ってきます
やばい
飛び込みかけてきたまだまだ早いよな失礼
します
おーすごい
うわー
これはいいですわ
店長もいらっしゃるんですけど基本件です
けど僕だけなんですけどいやこれパーツし
たかったねこんな
欲しかった8話は堅い
続いて中見ていきましょう
うわめっちゃ綺麗すごい見て
なんかさVIPルームみたいだよね空港の
天井もちゃんと高いんですよ
すごいちょっと待ってやばいやばい
もう
ホテルよ
お
すごいあと
枕の量もすごい
すごい
なんかこの中でもヒットが寝れると2人分
ですね何人寝るんだすごいね
おーこっちもベッドルームになってます
すごいたくさんの人泊まりそうですね
すごいめっちゃ快適じゃない
すごいなあさあ続きました上回るので上
行ってみましょうか
すごいよねこれが2億ですかこれが2億だ
よ
めっちゃカードゲームできそうこっちも
カードゲームできそうじゃないカード
ゲーム用なのここは
これは
完全にはいというわけでこんな感じの
超素敵な
国を貸して今日は素敵なクルージング
パーティーに行っていきたいと思います
なんかこっちにもですね
船の一番前にこういうシートがあるので
ここでもこうできるといるならここがいい
よねだってさ見ても全部見れるよここから
気持ちよさそうですねここでだって波風
当たるんでしょもう
全部どうでもいいや船の旅なんですけど
多分でも12時間ぐらいって帰ってくる
もんねまのんびりちょっとクルージングし
ながら12時間ぐらいして帰ってこいと
思いますいよいよ俺の服の旅が始ま
るってわけか
行ってきます
店長よろしくお願いします
はいというわけでついにクルージング
スタートしました
いやちょっとなんか
前の方が絶対いいから前に行ってくるね俺
うわ
めっちゃいいハゼ
気持ちを
[音楽]
気持ちよく寝てるところ
失礼いたします
壊れちゃってもう電気もないですで船に
1人取り残されちゃいました時の訓練が
だいぶ局所的だなでもさ室内とあんじゃん
ここにいる必要はないと思うんですよ僕
これやっぱ2億の船なんでセキュリティが
すごいんですよねはいはい
電気止まったら
絶対飽きません
ドアもなかった
それ1回見に行こうぜいやダメですって
ことは自室訓練ってことですねもう
実質訓練すねじゃルールとしてはそれ24
時間フレアのこの前の部分だけで
基本は1人で追加してもらいますここって
ことですよねまだきり夏なんでちょっと暑
さとか怖いしねこの24時間生活なんです
けど
食べ物とかどうなるんですかあと持ち物と
か
持ってないですか持ってないですじゃない
です
でも救済措置としてはい3時間に1回これ
触れます
来ましたねサイコロこちらになります
ちょっとこれ食べ物でもいいし鯛を強かっ
たりしたらさ気がさとかでもいいってこと
で苦手なと3時間電気がつくとどういう
ことですか
したら中に入れたじゃないですかまあ今は
入れない
電気がつくんですよ
3時間に帰ることはできないできません
遠くまで来てんだな3が出ると屋上で3
時間
屋上に入れるっていうはいね
日よけにはなりそうですねとりあえず
海にいればいいと海にいると落ちること
ありますからね
マジかで5がなしとまナシは1個は
仕方ないですお6めっちゃいい6が最高の
出たの好きなものなるほど
要するにもう1回振るってやつねそうです
6出て毎回6出たら好きなもの6個いって
こといけますわかりました訓練受けて立ち
ましょうそして1つはいさすがに
かわいそうじゃないですか先頭に
ちょこんと置いといて24時間も
かわいそうとかやばいよねそこでこちらを
どうぞ
でかい
これジャックリじゃないですかこれあれで
外でつければバッテリーですよねはい
じゃあなんか電気使うものをこれで使って
もいいってことねそれじゃあ扇風機とかも
いいってこと全然
冷風機もいい全然いいスマホ充電しても
いい全然パソコン使ってもいいと思います
好きなもの出た時に幅広がったね24時間
ずっと海の上電気だけがあるということ
ですねはいいやこれさ運悪かった俺何も
食べれないわけじゃない24時間
マジの遭難やんまあいいでしょう24時間
受けていたしますお疲れ様ですあれどこ
行くんだこれはあの
電気ついた中で
電気消えてんじゃないのかおいどういう
ことだよ
わかりましたというわけで今9時なので
明日の朝9時まで24時間
船の上生活スタートですまとりあえず
始まったものは仕方ないので
船の上で過ごそうと思いますとりあえず僕
の今持ってる持ち物だけ見てみましょうか
はい今回僕が持ってきた荷物です一応
海パンは持ってきた時に着替えも何着が
あるな着替え日焼け止め
イヤホンスマホの充電器
スーパーボール
財布
以上です水とジュースとサングラスもあり
ますねこんだけですやばい思ったより持っ
てきてなかったですいやけど今んところ
めっちゃ風気持ちいいから普通に船の旅
楽しみますねとりあえず3時間はいや
なかなかこんな優雅な24時間生活もない
ぞみんな
すげー
あの今んとこめっちゃ楽しいですお腹すい
てないですねただやっぱ
船の前結構揺れるのが気になっております
けども今僕乗り物に要因には強い方なんで
大丈夫です3時間ゆっくりしますね
[音楽]
ちょっと待ってください
太陽強い日焼け止め塗ります
[音楽]
じゃあおやすみ
ちょっと
待ってちょっと
待って
熱いよ強
うわタイマーうるさい
気持ちいいんですけど
太陽が熱いなって感じのある
[音楽]
10時から会議があるので買いに行ってき
ます
[音楽]
頑張ります
船酔いがやばいそういうの強い方だと思っ
てたんですけど
スマホずっと見てリモート回避してると
やばい
[音楽]
グッズ
モーニング
おはようございます3時間経ちました今の
気持ちはいやーちょっとね
温度ですね
太陽が痛いあと船酔いね前すごい揺れる
からやばいっすねそこらへんがまあ言うて
も3時間経ったということでサイコロ
回させていただきましたじゃあ行かして
いただきます
来い
ちょっと待ってそれやばいぞ
危ねえ
危ねえもう
落ちるから今の行きますね
好きなもの1つです
今お昼の12時でしょ
食事も撮りたいところなんですけどもご飯
は正直まだ何回もチャンスあると食べれる
という見込みあともうどっちかって船酔い
で食べ物どころじゃないとりあえず太陽を
交わしたいので日傘欲しいです
か
どうぞありがとうございますいや助かる
太陽がね本当に痛い海だからねそうそう
違いします
[音楽]
太陽から身を守ることをまず最優先して次
のサイコロでなんとかいいの出しますはい
というわけでずっとスマホを触ってて電池
がもうほぼなくなりかけてるのでちょっと
充電したいと思います今これビデオカメラ
も充電しながらずっと撮影しているので
24時間取れるしもう容量でかすぎて
スマホとか余裕で充電できると思うんすよ
ね
はい来ましたOk
残りがあ93%するこう3時間ビデオ
カメラ充電しっぱなしのまだ7%ですけど
も
せっかく今めちゃくちゃ太陽強いんで
ちょっとソーラーパネルで充電しながら
いきたいと思います
ベストナップパネル設置してこれで
ザクリを充電しながらスマホとビデオ
カメラの充電してるんでもうほぼ永久機関
よ
もう
海の真ん中みたいなとこにいますね
すげー
すごいやばい
[音楽]
やばい
太陽がやばい
[音楽]
船の揺れに
結構
順応してきたつもりであるんですけども
もうちょっと慣れたいね時間かけてという
わけで行きましょうか
6時間経ったのでは最高だーいいきます
ナイス
[音楽]
というわけでここで泳げるみたいですこれ
さあ
幽霊可能なさビーチとプールでしかお湯
ってことないからこういうなんか誰も人い
ないと初めてでちょっと震えてます
めっちゃ深いでしたって
使うよね
船長に許可いただいてやってるので皆さん
絶対真似しないでくださいこれは
この上で過ごせるよっていうなるほど
なかなかないですかね
本当によ
なかなかないしさやっぱ時間が長いように
結構
いやーまじ怖え
ぞあでも
気持ちいいめっちゃ暑かったからさいやで
も助かるこれ正解だったらに当たってあー
気持ちいいこの命綱
話せなよ
バカ
もう一回1回そこ行きたいあここ行きたい
[拍手]
1時間終了ですまあまあ
ゆっくりできてでも
遊び足りました
遊びちゃいました
[音楽]
よいしょ帰ってきましたいやマジで助かっ
た結構この酔いみたいなやつが経営された
というか海の中が冷たくてめっちゃ気持ち
よかったんでかなり助かりました今7時間
経過しましたねだいぶ夕方にもなってきた
ので日没までこの暑さには耐えようと思い
ます
[音楽]
はいというわけで5時になりました8時間
経過しましたねだいぶ日もくれてもう
そろそろ日が落ちて
夜になりそうなんですけども夕方ですね
あのさっきまでもうずっと熱い文句言って
たんですけども
ええと
寒いですちょっと1回ちゃんと着替えて
寒くなる一方だと思うのでなんとか夜を
乗り切れるようにしたいと思います
ちなみに今船の停泊場で止められる場所に
いるんですけども夜の間はここで船止め
ますただ僕はここから降りれないし船も
ずっと揺れてるので撮影には営業ないです
[音楽]
船長が帰りました
9時間経過しました
寒い
すごいね海って
太陽が落ちた瞬間めっちゃ寒くなりました
ねレバー風が強いからすごい冷気があって
も鳥肌が
わかる
ヤバいよ結構ピンチなんで
正直ここで4位引いたら僕はもう終わり
です
室内に行けたら助かります
126あたりやっていきたいと思います
いや俺悪いけど空気がまず6出すからね
ここでもう
結構ピンチいきます
行ってきます
よーしこっから3時間は上ということです
ねいやいや
全然
風強いやん風強いからこっちには行かずに
この
屋根あるここら辺にいたいですねここら辺
にいたいと思います
[音楽]
皆さんこれ今風の強さ分かると思うんす
けど時計ぶっ飛ぶぐらい風強いです
うわあ
[音楽]
はいというわけでもうすぐ12時間経過
しようとしてますあと40分ぐらいかな
現状の状態言うと
寒すぎます僕今気づいたんですけど何も
食べてないんですよ企画始まってから12
時間何も食べれない多分体が衝撃する
カロリーなくなってきてる気がするんで
そろそろ何か食べたいなと思ってます
とりあえずあと40分
耐えます
時間が経ちましたありがとうございまーす
12時間
終了折り返しです
ただただ
過酷というわけでこれが今日最後かなこれ
終わるともう12時になっちゃうんでマジ
で大事です変なの出したらマジで
ワンチャン
いやもう本当なんか飯食いたいのもでかい
正直
体温が下がってきてるから16
狙えたらいいかなと思ってます
[音楽]
よろしくお願いします行かせていただき
ます
[音楽]
3時間電気つくややった
飯食えないのかということで9時から12
時まで3時間は電気が復旧したという
体で新宿教科ってことですか
開いてるわ
これが
電子制御
ドアか
エースだろう
うわぁめっちゃ渋谷に風のない空間に行き
ますお邪魔します
あっ
たっけこんなあったかいんやから日本に
まだあったといやー
すげーマジで助かりました
本当にここで寝て今もうこれやめて
ください
船の中なんで濡れてますね若干
させてください
おやすみなさい
[音楽]
一睡もできませんでしたというわけで12
時なので15時間経過しましたね今シェア
の12時なんですけどもマジでリアルな
ことを考えるともう次絶対外出るじゃない
ですかこれ引かない限り何かこう防寒具が
ないとおそらく僕
絶滅するんですよ1時間海で俺もうほんと
終わりですから1時間見れたらちょっと
もうエンディング入るかもしれない人生の
エンディングがあるかもしれないねいき
ます
来い
やったー
いやもう1回で
好きなもの何か1個手に入
るってことでしょ1個以上はね
[音楽]
やばいめっちゃ見えた1から6位以外だっ
たらマジで俺無理でしたよこれ6個出せば
いってことねでかい目指せでかい目指せ
いきます
[音楽]
[拍手]
好きなもの5個いけます
急に楽しくなってきちゃったのこれ
危なかったさっきまでちょっと
防寒具系3つぐらい笑っちゃおっかな
じゃあそこに結構ね費やす感じでしょ
ですよね5つまず
毛布ここから3時まででしょ
寝ると思うので
毛布欲しいですあとザクレで電気使えるん
でしょ
ヒーターなしです
回してくださいあと
厚木のパーカーが欲しいですね
任せてくださいあと2つですよねあと2つ
です
食べ
[音楽]
物です
か
1つでいいでしょそれもいいですか15
時間もねさすがにね頑張ってるんで
ありがとうございます
焼肉はできないらしくてさっき
屋上で過ごしたと思うんですけどまあそこ
で食べることになりますそしてもう1つは
すぐ食べれるものが
すぐ食べれるんだっ3つある方です海とか
で入ってるからさ
体力消耗が
いいですか1個使っていいんですけど
今日の初ご飯がまさかの深夜やろいただき
ます
[音楽]
新しいさん
先に服も渡しときますうわめちゃくちゃ
いい感じですいい感じですというわけで
続いて
焼肉でーす
いやすごいなぁちゃんとホットプレート
まであるんですけどもなんせ電源がないの
でどうするかっていうとざっくりを使って
いきましょう
温めていきますこっちり
早速
焼いちゃおうかなやっと中サバイバル生活
っぽくなってきたよ
待って待ってまじうまそうなんだけど
やばいはいはいはいOkOkよしよし
じゃあ早速いただきますいただきます
[音楽]
船生活最高はいというわけで無事素敵な
夜ご飯食べることができましたマジで
助かったたやっぱりご飯食べても長袖着て
も寒いのでここからさらに笑ったヒーター
そして毛布を使ってちょっとあったまり
ながら外で生活していきたいと思います
とりあえずヒート使いますね
便利すぎでしょ俺どんだけ今日電気使っ
てるの外で行くぜこれであったかいのが
出るかどうかですね全然オンあ来た来た来
た
[音楽]
よしじゃあ十分ですこれでだけの環境が
あれば俺は外でも寝れるおやすみ
[音楽]
おはようございます
ケニーです
3時です
温度的には
最高に気持ちいいます
[音楽]
おやすみなさい
ついに
最後の3時間ですもう6時
ラストダンスお願いします行くねはい
いやー
求めません行きます
[音楽]
1時間海
ラストタイムです
頑張れよ
逆だいただきますね
なんで今なんや
うわぁ
ダミー
じゃあまたちょっと立ったら行きます
[音楽]
ちょ調子良かったね最後の方
雨強くないそして今日間違いすぎでしょ俺
だってああいう風な奴とかお
疲れ様でした
ありがとうございました
[音楽]
怖いよー
23時間経過しましたあと1時間
雨が強くて
やばいです
寒い
いやこれを変えれば
俺の勝ちだー
やばい
何が想像して今
ありがとうございます
はいというわけで残り時間5分となりまし
た
岸の近くまで来たので波が結構落ち着いて
きました
壮絶な旅でしたねあんまり動いたり運動し
てたわけじゃないんですけど
暑さと寒さそして船酔い想像していたより
結構
厳しいサバイバル生活になりましたけども
それも最後の方結構船酔いとか慣れて普通
になんか寝れてたんでそこは助かりました
[音楽]
終了です
終わりましたー
苦しかったけど楽しかったなぁ
海の過酷さと素晴らしさをした24時間
でしたねー
[音楽]
じゃあ
地上に足つきますね
24時間ぶりの地上だからね
行きます
[音楽]
揺れてないねはい24時間生活が終了し
ましたいやー
電気がなかったので本当にこの子のおかげ
ですジャックリのおかげでなんとか無事に
生還することができたと言えますでこの
弱点なんですけども
ソーラージェネレーターカテゴリーの
リーディングカンパニーです
簡単に言うとポータブル電源って色々ある
じゃないですかそれのもうトップなんです
よここなんと世界累計販売台した200万
台で突破しておりますもう
素晴らしいそしてこのジャックにAC90
点あの
コンセントでの充電とソーラー急速充電を
搭載しております僕も途中で使ったと思う
んですけれどもどちらもわずか1点に8
時間でフル充填というすごい速さでござい
ますさらに安全と安心で長い時間長い期間
使える商品になっています
家電製品とか色々買うと保証とかつくん
ですけどもなんとザクに5年保証です小学
生が育っちゃう
ぐらいちょっと普通に僕もこれ使いたいと
思うんでぜひ気になった方は動画の概要欄
からチェックしてみてくださいじゃ次は
バナナボート24時間生活でお会いし
ましょうじゃあな頑張れ健介絶対無理で
[音楽]